[Music]
what kind of questions can science not
currently answer and may never be able
to answer yeah
is there an intelligence out there
that's underlies the whole thing you can
call them with the G word if you want I
can say are we a computer simulation
with a purpose is there an agent an
intelligent agent that underlies or is
responsible for the whole thing
does that intelligent agent satisfy the
laws of physics does it satisfy the laws
of quantum mechanics is it made of atoms
and molecules yeah there's a lot of
questions and I don't see this it seems
to me a real question
it's an answerable question well I'm
answerable the questions have to be
answerable to be real some philosophers
would say that a question is not a
question unless it's answerable this
question doesn't seem to me answerable
by any known method but it seems to me
real
you